se habla de gúdar como una figura
rupturista que con su arte vino a
cambiar el cine que fue lo más
característico de su obra y cuál es su
principal legado en el arte hola buenas
tardes buenas gracias por invitarme pues
efectivamente por dar esta mañana
recordaba unas palabras que él usó para
calificar a chaplin en el año 63 en
calle de cinema cuando ya era director y
decía está por encima de todo elogio
porque es el más grande y bueno yo creo
que hoy puesto que decía esto de jan
luego dar porque aunque desde hace
bastante tiempo pues hacía un cine más
ensayo que cine narrativo y eran un poco
misántropo digamos lo que él hizo
básicamente entre el año 60
e hizo sin aliento como he dicho en
español la conocemos como 'al final de
la escapada' y en francés ese apunte
soufflet hasta el año 67 entre esos en
esos 7 años hizo ocho películas
absolutamente maravillosas
incontestables que
cambiaron el rumbo del exterior del cine
y de repente pues dio una vuelta a todo
ese cine que llamaba al cine clásico
lo que construyó que es una palabra que
se dice ahora con mucha facilidad pero
para deconstruir algo pues hay que
conocerlo muy bien el conocía el cine
muy bien se había formado en bueno en
las salas de la cinemateca francesa y
reinventó repito el cine es el cine que
consideramos moderno nace con jean-luc
godard con la nu verdad que antes que él
ya había triunfado el otro gran cineasta
era no verdad que fue triunfo en en
canela en el 59 con los 400 golpes y
bueno goldar pues es el otro gran
cineasta de este movimiento francés que
estaba muy unido al neorrealismo por
otro lado sin tener nada que verlo con
sacar la cámara a la calle con equipos
ligeros y tomar el pulso a la realidad
como decía pues todo ese cine que
consideramos moderno que nace con cómo
dar que era mucho más rupturista que
triunfó y bueno pues gente como
tarantino o como wong kar wai pues no
serían lo que son sin sin volar sí y más
allá del cine que significó dar en lo
político y en lo social como hombre
comprometido con la clase obrera y en el
movimiento del 68 en concreto bueno
lugar ya en sus películas en estas
películas tampoco de los comienzos de
los 60 ya introducía el tema de el tema
político el tema de la guerra de vietnam
y del imperialismo que estaba muy en
boga en aquel momento en una incluida el
contexto histórico que es el de la
guerra fría de la guerra de vietnam el
de máó
roberts y forma egoísta
para mí para otras personas pues ahí se
desinfló un poco el talento de debo dar
la brillantez al hipotecar ese talento y
ese desparpajo que tenía pues al
servicio de unas ideas políticas por
otro lado pues eran legítimas claro él
fue uno de los que se subieron al
estrado en el festival de cannes del año
68 y pararon la proyección y ahí
suspendieron el festival de él y su
amigo
dijo que por cierto también estaba allí
carlos saura y elías querejeta que eran
españoles y estaban allí con él me lo
contaba mi infeliz querejeta bueno eso
el enfoque o dar abandonas ese cine
narrativo y ese cine tan pop y si es que
es un cine militante que quería ser
grupo figa vértov
aunque era un cine
cooperativista hay una película francesa
muy divertida y que retrata poder
abordar que es el de la redoute hable de
de miserias a novicios con rica relación
de godard el que se cuenta muy bien esto
no es bueno andar en un tipo muy
brillante también controvertido y con
muchas contradicciones entonces en esa
película se ve esta construcción del
cine cooperativista y lo divertido que
era y lo frustrante que tal vez alguien
del talento y el genio de votar qué
cabrón renunciar a la autoría cuando él
había reivindicado la autoría de tantos
pues era muy complicado
bueno que yo creo que era un hombre
lleno de contradicciones genial en
cualquier caso y que para mí y para
otras personas pues su apuesta de uno no
es porque pensás de tener la forma sino
si no bueno pues por querer apostar por
ese camino